كلمه اذا مشاهدينا كنا نستمع اليها للرئيس
الاوكراني فروديميرازيلينسكي من داخل
الكونجرس الامريكي حول ما جاء فيها معنى
من هناك اذا من الكونجرس مراسله الجزيره
بيسان ابو كويك وتنضم الينا ايضا من البيت
الابيض مراسلاتنا وجد وقفي اهلا بكما ابدا
بك لسان ابو كويك كذا من الكونجرس
الامريكي اذا اهم الرسائل في هذه الكلمه
للرئيسكي
[موسيقى]
سفيان الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير سيلنسكي
توجه بشكل مباشر للمشرعين الامريكيين وحتى
للشعب الامريكي ايضا
طالبا استمرار تقديم الدعم والمساعده من
قبل الولايات المتحده لاوكرانيا تحدث عن
ما ساهمت فيه هذه المساعدات حتى الان
وبقاء طبعا الاوكرانيين صامدين في ارض
المعركه ولكنه تحدث ايضا عن ما يحتاجونه
لقلب المعادله والنصر وشدد في هذه الجزئيه
تحديدا على ضروره مواصله الدعم الامريكي
تحدث عن المعركه والجبهه في باخمط قائلا
ان لديهم ذخيره ولكنها ليست كافيه همم قلب
همم الوضع هناك في تلك المعركه تحدث ايضا
عن التعاون الامريكي
الاوكراني على عده صعود ان كان العسكريه
والدعم الامري حتى لبناء المؤسسات وجيش
قوي اوكراني وانه يريد مواصله ذلك وان هذه
الحرب هي ليست فقط طبعا في اوكرانيا
ولكنها لها تداعيات على العالم باسره وعلى
مستقبل الديمقراطيه كما قال في العالم
ايضا تحدث عن المساعدات التي من المتوقع
ان يصادق عليها الكونجرس في موازنه عامه
داعيا او يعني حتى شاكر بشكل اصطباقي
المشرعين لتمريرها همم ربما ضرب ايضا على
بعض الاوطار التي ربما اعتاد ذلك الحديث
عنها تحدث عن معركه صار توجا في الحرب
الاهلي
الامريكيه قائلا ان الاوكرانيين طبعا
يطرقون الى تحقيق النصر مثل تلك المعركه
ايضا همم استخدم او لاعب على الكلام فيما
يتعلق بصوراخ باتريوت بالقول طبعا باللغه
الانجليزيه تعني وطنيا وقال ان بطاريات او
صواريخ باتريوت ستساعد اا الوطنيين او
البيطريوتس الاوكرانيين في مواصله حربهم
تحدث ايضا عن مبادره السلام الذي كان قد
تقدم بها وقال ان الرئيس دعم تلك المبادره
وان المعادله للسلام تتضمن نقاطا يجب
ينبغي ويجب تنفيذها لضمان الامن المشترك
للعقود القادمه قال ان النصر في هذه الحرب
هي سترسم وستحدد العالم الذي سيعيش فيه
الاولاد
والاحفاد في المستقبل تحدث ايضا همم عن
همم صواريخ الروسيه وهاجمه ايران التي
زودت همم اقرا عفوا روسيا بالمسيرات وكيف
تستخدم تلك المسيارات في الحرب
واشار الى ان المساعدات التي تقدم من
الولايات المتحده ليست صدقه او عملا خيريا
بل انها استثمار في الامن والسلم العالمي
واا ايضا تحدث بالعوده طبعا الى موضوع
المسيارات قائلا انها تشكل تهديدا للدنيا
التحتيه وتحدث ايضا عن فصل الشتاء
والاعياد التي ستاتي في وقت تم الضرب فيه
همم لا يعيش فيه الاوكرانيين دون كهرباء
او همم مياه ولكنه شدد على انهم يحتفلون
باعياد الميلاد رغم كل تلك الظروف
واشار الى ان يعني تحدث كثيرا عن الصمود
ربما الاوكراني ونال ذلك تصفيقا كبيرا
داخل القاعه قال ان البعض كان تتوقع سقوط
اوكرانيا وسقوط اكياس وطبعا نذكر ان في
بدايه الحرب اتوقعات الامريكيه قبيله حرب
كانت النفير ستسقط خلال فتره وجيزه ولكنه
قال ان اوكرانيا ضلت صامده
وتقاتل وحيه وتقاتل بشده وان الطغيان
الروسي كما قال فقد سيطراته على
الاوكرانيين وتحدث ايضا عن ان الاوكرانيين
لا يشعرون باي خوف همم لان المعركه ليست
فقط على الارض ولكنها من اجل الاجيال
القادمه لذا سفيان هذه الكلمه زلينسكي قبل
همم بها كان قد اجتمع
بقيادات الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين في مجلس
الشيوخ وما مجلس النواب وحاول مخاطبه
اصوات مشككه تحديدا في مجلس النواب من
الجمهوريين بشكل مباشر للحديث عن هذه
القيم القيم الحريه والسلم والامان
العالمي وان هذه الحرب هي حرب تعبر
المحيطات وليست فقط تقتصر على الحدود
الاوكرانيه مصعاه
يعني اقناعهم بمواصله تقديم المساعدات
لاوكرانيا
لوجده وقفي من البيت الابيض وجد يعني كما
شاهدنا في هذه الصور ترحيب كبير وحار من
قبل اعضاء الكونجرس بيه الرئيس جنسكي دعم
امريكي متواصل كما ااه اشرنا يعني هل من
تحفظات اذا بشان هذا الدعم وهذه الزياره
للرئيس الاوكراني الى همم واشنطن والى
الولايات المتحده في هذا التوقيت خاصه
وانه هناك من يربط ربما هذه الزياره وهذه
المساعدات وتسريعها في هذا التوقيت
التغيرات ربما في الكونغرس القادمه في همم
مطلع العام
ههه بالنسبه للاصوات المعارضه هناك بعض
الاصوات للجمهوريين المعارضه
كما يقولون منح اوكرانيا والرئيس جيلنسكي
شيكا على بياض
هؤلاء معظمهم موجودين تحديدا في مجلس
الشيوخ ولهذا ربما سفيان رات الاداره
الامريكيه من الضروره بمكان الرئيس
الاوكراني ان يخاطب اعضاء الكونجرس
وبالتالي ايضا ان يخاطب الشعب الامريكي من
خلال هذه الكلمه في رساله مفادها كما قال
زيلانسكي الصمود صمود حتى النصر لكن هذا
الصمود بحاجه الى ذخائر بحاجه الى اسلحه
نظرا لتفوق العسكري لروسيا على اوكرانيا
وبان هذا الامر لن يتم الا من خلال تسلم
اوكرانيا مساعدات عسكريه ومساعدات عسكريه
كبيره لانها تدافع ذلك ليس فقط عن بلادها
وعن اوكرانيا بل ايضا عن اوروبا باسرع حتى
انه قال ان اوروبا اصبحت اليوم اكثر
استقلالا واكثر حريه مما كانت عليه من ذي
قبل اذن هذه هي رسالته لتحديدا المشككين
في جدول استمرار تدفق المساعده ولكن حسب
البيت الابيض سفيان هم على ثقه من ان حزم
المساعدات الامريكيه سواء المئتين
المليارات دولار والتي تتضمن بطاريات
الباتريوت الدفاعيه او ال 45 مليار دولار
ضمن ميزانيه العام المقبل هي 45 مليار
دولار رصدتها اداره كمساعدات للعام المقبل
لاوكرانيا الاداره الامريكيه واثقه وعبرت
عن ثقتها باكثر من مره
الكونجرس سوف يصادق على هذه
الميزانيه ولكن يبدو ان كلمه ازيلينسكي في
الكونجرس جاءت لي كمحاوله طبعا اي شك عن
اليقين اليقين كانت كلمه لدى الرئيس
الامريكي حقيقه عندما سئل هو والرئيس
الاوكراني خلال المؤتمر الصحفي هنا في
البيت الابيض عن كيفيه انهاء الحرب وكيف
سيكون شكل نهايه هذا الحرب اكد بايظ بان
نهايته ستكون عندما تكون اوكرانيا على
يقين بانهم انتصرت في هذه الحرب وان
الانتصار يعني سيادتها
وسلامه اراضيها جميعا
من البيت الابيض وكذلك من الكونغرس مراسله
الجزيره بلسانه شكرا جزيلا لكم